[Music]
all right tonight is the first night of
shooting for the Far Cry 3 Blood Dragon
video that we're doing and we're here at
Hollywood Sports parka it's actually a
huge paintball airsoft field but they
have this humongous banquet ball here
that we've filled with arcade machines
from the arcade next door the coolest
place to have an action scene in the
future is a post-apocalyptic arcade
mansion thing so we're gonna decorate
this place with neon lights turn on all
the machines hopefully it looks really
sweet so as you guys know we do a lot of
action videos without a bunch of guns
and military stuff there realize we
should probably actually start playing
airsoft and put those guns to good use
so this park is actually one of the park
that we most visit because there's
really cool areas and it's actually
pretty close to our place we actually
play airsoft here almost every other
weekend so if you're in the area you
should come down and play with us
maybe we can battle I actually really
excited to see all the costumes
on-camera costumes go a long way to
production quality you open the bag you
see a VHS tape and a nuclear detonator
and so you can figure out what it's all
about so oh yeah you guys are all robots
you guys are more like cyborgs robots
and the xr2 no you punch it he's like
clenching your hand and then with this
app you'll have the sword sheath by now
and why get an insert shot where you
grab his other hand that has the
detonator in it and you just like
literally rip it out of his hand you're
in you're an Android and super fast I
can't help it
[Music]
Oh
here's really and three two one go
well that's pretty good more Drive one
more time
last tape last tape this is last night
no matter what 3 2 1 throw great awesome
right now we are setting up the wide
intro reveal shot for the entire arcade
and so using this suite Liebeck jib arm
here to basically start down low take a
look at this claw machine operating hand
up to the chandelier is turning on and
then pending back down to have all the
rest of the screens kind of start
flickering the life as we cool and
action well I guess that means you that
alright um let's try a variation like
you're really bad at breaking bad news
the people
how would you so how would you do that
though how do you express that how would
you do that
like you know it's awkward but it's
making you uncomfortable that you have
to deliver it and you're just trying to
like plate nonchalant like see it's no
big deal I don't care
hug your shoulders yeah you're telling
someone they're like terminal cancer but
you're trying to be like cool about it
so they don't freak out all right poorly
directing miss Ambrose key like usual as
in the middle of getting a cool shot and
the power shuts off we don't have access
to the circuit breaker here so while we
try and figure that out we're all gonna
go eat some food and hopefully uh the
problem solves itself by the time we're
done eating well so what time is it that
were you lunch dude lunch time at
midnight exactly midnight so I don't
know fajitas for lunch tonight
[Music]
all right so that's a wrap on day one
probably the most pictures tweeted from
my set ever with this one just because
of all the sweet sets and all the sweet
costumes and all the glowing neon colors
and right now it's south have is it 5:17
a.m. 5:17 a.m. we've been here since
about what like 5:30 so a bowl 12 hours
in this crazy room we're gonna go home
and sleep and then come right back and
shoot again tomorrow night blow up an
entire city with a nuke oh hello there
we're just here on the Apoc map at
Hollywood Sports Park to shoot this epic
apocalyptic scene bolt lightning comes
out and runs into the city he's hunted
down his cyborg companion CX 89 he's
been taken by the virus in CX 89 is
staying on top of a car with a button to
the nuclear bomb destroy neo Angeles so
we're shooting here utilizing this very
apocalyptic looking city rubble map to
keep the feel down we're gonna have bars
with a propane tanks hooked up basically
fancy grilles on some buckets of
charcoal with some stuff in them that
puts out smoke we're gonna make this
place look like it's all destroyed and
we have a giant light the biggest light
we've ever used it's hooked up to a
giant generator that can pump out like a
thousand amps that's me our nuclear bomb
it's very strange being on this
paintball map flash airsoft Matt because
we play you're pretty often walking
around the map without my protection
it's just like it's like being able to
breathe underwater
so anyways I got some cool stuff I got
cars I got jets they got fake concrete
then maybe that's real okay I don't know
really tired after being up until 5:00
a.m. last night so our plan today is
basically to like have a half days worth
of shots and then a whole night to shoot
it so should be a little more relaxed be
able to make everything look really good
make sure that fire is lined up
perfectly for every shot pretty sweet we
are setting up a flame ball it's to add
fire effect in the back
like cars on fire you know just general
fires in the background it's nice safe
coats propane and shut off a wing wants
and it gets better source if anything
does catch fire it should just be
something really small so it's easy park
lights go off in a half hour when it
happens I hit record and hopefully we
have a smooth night of shooting we
actually have less to shoot tonight but
so seeing that has a lot more spectacle
so we want to make sure that we take our
time in shooting every shot as cool as
we can that's why we have the GM out
here we're gonna be putting every single
shot on the trip dolly track with Jim R
gets huge swooping camera movements look
like a huge nuclear explosion going off
in the background and yeah so that's the
plan tonight just make everything look
as cool as we can in the time we have
and try not to rush it too much because
that happened a little bit last night
not that it was a problem so tonight
we're going to be using some flame
buckets and what is it's charcoal with
frankincense in it which is basically
like this tree sap I think they also
have some artificial stuff now - and
what does when you put it in it kind of
a bites into smoke and the smoke is
relatively fine to breathe
they actually use in a lot of churches
and stuff like that you know the monks
with the swinging things so this type of
a system is best used outdoors because
it can produce a lot of smoke to cover a
large area within while smoke machines
usually pretty centralized and doesn't
really spread out as much also hazers
and foggers they can produce quite a bit
but the thing is is that usually
dissipates pretty easily outside and
this frankincense actually stays in the
air quite long and it's actually pretty
surprising you'll see how it works later
I proceeded to be invincible and murder
everybody on the other team yeah look
over here I'll check this out Nico is in
the building right there on the left and
I was in the bus and I remember like I
was sitting there holding tons of people
off an iPad I I don't I panned over I
pan over with my eyes I see like Nico
like walking in through the like windows
like hip firing like bit literally hip
firing just killing people I turn over
like
oh crap he's invincible and I don't like
turnin get the crap out of there until I
got to this side there's like a bunch of
enemy teammates just like down the wall
I'm walking behind them and they're like
surrender I'm like you can't surrender
me I'm the juggernaut and you see like
it's like I went shoot him fire you
that's a juggernaut did you explain how
a jogger that works here it really is
pretty self okay yeah yeah that's 9:28
p.m. right now we are going through some
cool choreography basically we're
figuring out this entire katana battle
with the laser katanas and we're setting
up lights at the same time if you can
see that giant lens flare right over
there that is our humongous 24k light
it's the brightest light I've ever seen
in my entire life
next is the Sun we're gonna get use it
in the scene because it's going to
simulate the light of a nuclear
explosion so bright light fire smoke all
the stuff rushing by while these guys
are battling out with futures and swords
hopefully it's gonna be cool
[Music]
looks like it's going to be a lovely
Thursday morning here at the set
everybody did a kick-ass job the shots
looked amazing don't know I do without
everybody helping out because films are
a team effort and you're all gonna make
something that's awesome the whole team
I'm rambling it's because I haven't
slept in a long time Iowa's Forest Park
once again banks selling a shoot here
it's an awesome place you guys got the
chance to definitely come play airsoft
paintball here they like a projector
inside it's looking like do stuff what
they'll do is they'll go and they'll get
a bunch of old set pieces like various
movies and use it to decorate the park
so it actually gives the place a really
unique aesthetic it's like it's more
decorated than any other airsoft park
I've been to it's actually like legit
props movies and stuff maybe this is
from Starship Troopers
that's about it see you guys later
[Music]
you